depuis quand je vous avez des idées
suicidaires
vous appelez coin longtemps
des années d'accord donc vous avez envie
mettre fin au genre depuis des années et
pourquoi
pourquoi maintenant du coup
qu'est-ce qui est ce qu'il ya eu des
choses qui ont fait que ça s'est
intensifié la depuis dernièrement
on
ou on est là pour écouter la souffrance
mais nous ne sommes pas une ligne
d'écouté à proprement parler on est une
ligue où on évalue le risque suicidaire
et on évalue la crise et on intervient
si besoin est on peut faire intervenir
des secours puisqu'on a le samu qui est
juste en bas et on travaille avec eux
avec la régulation samu ce qui nous
permet en fait de géolocaliser les
appels si besoin
[Musique]
l'ensemble de la population a découvert
entre guillemets l'importance de la
santé mentale avec cette crise parce
qu'on n'a été soumis à des stress
intense nos capacités d'adaptation ont
été mises à mal il a fallu s'adapter au
confinement ou déconfinement re
confinement
[Musique]
des facteurs qui expliquent qu'ils aient
encore plus de suicides en france que
ailleurs c'est que c'est un sujet qui
reste tabou dont on n'ose pas parler que
ce soit lorsqu'on est soi-même assailli
par des idées suicidaires ou lorsqu'on
est proche de quelqu'un qui qui pourrait
être suicidaire